so maybe what are spinners let's start
with spinner because i think that if we
can introduce that then i can
by the way
twister spelled with an o
and spinner is spelled with an o as well
yes okay so in case you want to google
it and look it up that's very nice
wikipedia pages as a starting point i
don't know what is a good starting point
for twister theory
one thing to say about penrose i mean
penrose is actually a very good writer
and also very good draftsman he's on
drafts he to the extent this is
visualizable he actually has done some
very nice drawings so i mean almost any
kind of expository thing you can find
him writing is is a very good a good
place to start he's a
he's a remarkable person but the um
so
spinners are something that
independently came out of mathematics
and out of physics
and um to say where they came out of
physics i mean what people realized when
they started looking at elementary
particles like electrons or whatever
that there there seem to be
there seems to be some kind of doubling
of the degrees of freedom going on if
you
counted
what was there in some sense in the way
you would expect it and when you started
doing quantum mechanics and started
looking at elementary particles they
were seen to be two degrees of freedom
they're not one
and one way of seeing it was that if you
um
if you put your electron in a strong
magnetic field
and ask and ask what was the energy of
it instead of it having one energy it
would have two energies there'd be two
energy levels and as you
increase magnetic field the splitting
would increase so
physicists kind of realize that wait a
minute so in we thought when we were
doing it first start doing quantum
mechanics that the way to describe
particles was in terms of wave functions
and these wave functions were complex to
complex values well
if we actually look at particles that
that's not right they're they're they're
pairs of complex numbers
so you know why so one of the kind of
fundamental from the physics point of
view the fundamental question is why are
all our kind of fundamental particles
described by pairs of complex numbers
just weird and then but if you go and
then then you can ask you know what
happens if you like
take an electron and rotate it so how
how do things move in this this pair of
complex numbers
well now if you go back to mathematics
what had been
been understood in mathematics you know
some years earlier not that many years
earlier was that if you um
if you ask very very generally think
about geometry of three dimensions and
ask
and if you think about things that are
happening in three dimensions
in the standard way everything the
standard way of doing geometry
everything is about vectors
right so if you've
if you're taking any mathematics classes
you probably see vectors at some point
they're just triplets of numbers tell
you
what a direction is or how far you're
going in three dimensional space and
most of everything we teach in most
standard courses in
mathematics is about vectors and things
you build out of vectors so you express
everything about geometry in terms of
vectors or how they're changing or how
you put two of them together and get
planes and
whatever but what
had been realized that early on is that
if you ask very very generally what are
the if you have
what are the things that that you can
kind of consistently think about
rotating
and um
and you can so you you ask a technical
question what are the representations of
the rotation group well you you find
that their one answer is their vectors
and everything you build out of vectors
but then people found but wait a minute
there's also these other things
which you can't build out of vectors
but which you can consistently rotate
and they're they're described by pairs
of complex numbers by two complex
numbers and they're they're they're the
spinners also and
to make a lot and to make and and you
can think of spinners in some sense as
more fundamental than vectors because
you can build vectors out of spinners
you can take two spinners and make a
vector
but you can't
you can't if you only have vectors you
can't get spinners
so there in some sense at there's some
kind of level of lower level of geometry
beyond what we thought it was which was
kind of spinner geometry
and this is something which
even to this day when we teach graduate
courses in geometry we mostly
don't talk about this because it's a bit
it's a bit hard to hard to do correctly
if you start if you start with your
whole setup is in terms of vectors
getting describing things in terms of
spinners is a whole different ballgame
but um
the but so but anyway it was just this
amazing fact that this
this kind of more fundamental piece of
geometry spinners and what we were
actually seeing if you look at electron
are one in the same
so it's a
i think it's kind of kind of a
mind-blowing thing but it it's very uh
un counter-intuitive
what are some weird properties of
spinners that are currently counter
intuitive
there are some things that they do for
instance if you rotate a spinner around
360 degrees it doesn't come back to
where it's it it becomes minus what it
was
so it's
anyway so so the way rotations work
there's a kind of a funny sign you have
to keep track of in some sense um so
they're kind of too valued in a way
another weird way but there's one but
the fundamental problem is that it's
just not
if you're used to visualizing
vectors you just there's nothing you can
do visualize in terms of vectors that
will ever give you a spinner it just is
not going to ever work
as you were saying that i was
visualizing a vector walking along a
mobius strip
yeah and it ends up being upside down
um but you're saying that doesn't really
capture
so i mean what really captures it the
pro the problem is that it's really
the simplest way to describe it is in
terms of two complex numbers and your
problem with two complex numbers is
that's four real numbers so
your spinner kind of lies in a four
dimensional space so you
that makes it hard to visualize and
it's crucial that it's not just any four
dimensions it's just it's actually
complex numbers you're really going to
use the fact that
these are the complex numbers so it um
it's very hard to visualize but but to
get back to what i think is mind-blowing
about twisters
is that the
another way of saying this this idea
about talking about spheres another way
of saying the fundamental idea of
twister theory is
in some sense the fundamental idea of
twister theory is that a point
is a two
is a two complex dimensional space so
that every
and that it lives inside the space that
it lies inside is twister space so in
the simplest case it's
for twister space is four-dimensional
and
a point in space-time is a two-complex
dimensional
um
subspace of the of all the four complex
dimensions and as you move around in
space-time you're just moving your
planes are just moving around okay and
that and but but then the it's a it's a
plane in a four-dimensional space it's a
yeah it's playing complex complex planes
so it's two complex dimensions in four
comics
okay but then to me the mind-blowing
thing about this is this then
kind of tautologically answers the
question is what is a spinner well
a spinner is a point i mean the space of
spinners at a point is the point in
twister theory
the points are the complex two planes
and and you want me to and you're asking
what a spinner is
well a spinner the space of spinners is
that two plane
so it's you know just
your whole definition of what a pointed
space time was just
told you what a spinner was it's they're
just it's the same thing yeah we're
trying to project that into a
three-dimensional space and trying to
intuit but yeah
yeah so the intuition becomes very
difficult but um but
from if you don't you not using twister
theory
you have to kind of go through a certain
fairly complicated rigmarole to even
describe spinners to describe electrons
whereas using twister theory is just
completely tautological they're just
what you want
to describe
the electron is
fundamentally the way you're describing
the point in space time already it's
just there
you